quels sont les éléments importants à
retenir pour être un allié avec les
autochtones
oui bienvenue à paroles tonnes si ces
mises à mort depuis sept semaines pour
répondre à la question des jeunes
je vais te donner quelques trucs mais je
peux te dire une chose c'est que ça peut
pas être généralisé pour tout l'ensemble
de la population des premières nations
mais ceux qui ont toujours bien
fonctionné pour moi c'est donc dans une
interaction avec un allié ce sont les
suivantes
alors la première chose c'est d'arriver
humblement ne pas vouloir arrivé en
sauveur
si je te sauver matin et dim c'est dire
écoute je veux t d mais je sais pas quoi
faire
j'aimerais ça pouvoir te donner un coup
de main parce que la réconciliation
c'est important pour moi parce que
protéger la forêt boréale c'est
important pour moi quand les gens
approche avec humilité c'est toujours
plus ouvert que quand ils veulent nous
sauver oubliez jamais que quand ils ont
voulu nous surveillons créer les
passionnants et en fait les réserves
essayez pas de nous sauver mais ouvrez
ouvrez votre coeur
et là vous allez avoir plus de chance
justement de pouvoir avoir une
interaction qui est faite d'humain à
humain
quand c'est que justement vouloir
défaire des injustices dans les
programmations sont victimes
un autre un autre point je te dirai qui
est très importante et on en parle
beaucoup ces temps-ci de vouloir porter
avec les premières nations
le poids de la réconciliation le poids
la réparation d'études de défaire avec
la décolonisation justement de tout ce
qui nous est arrivé
porter ce poids avec nous ne nécessite
pas un de devenir nous c'est à dire de
pouvoir de vouloir est autochtone pour
pouvoir porter ce poids là vous pouvez
le porter en restant des québécois
d'ailleurs c'est le poids de du
privilège d'être québécois non
autochtone qui vont nous aider le plus
parce que vous allez faire entendre
notre voix est une autre chose qui est
quand même très important aussi c'est
comprendre que l'émotion que vous vivez
des fois elle vous frappe de plein fouet
mais nous on la porte depuis longtemps
dont la charge émotionnelle de
devoir réconcilier les alliés avec
l'histoire qu'ils vivent peut être très
difficile et très lourde et vous
comprendrez que c'est pas parce qu'on
veut pas avoir la même sensibilité pour
vous c'est juste que des fois ça peut
être très lourd donc l'entendre une fois
2 x 20 x 30 x ça peut devenir l'eau et
c'est pas parce qu'on veut mettre de
côté vous votre réaction à l'histoire
que vous êtes en train de découvrir
c'est vraiment parce que nous autres on
la vit encore quotidiennement et que ce
polar continue toujours avec les autres
combats qu'on compte comme un allié un
ailier je dirais que c'est souvent vrai
que c'est comme sur une guerre c'est que
c'est sur un champ de bataille
puis on a besoin d'alliés pour nos
champs de bataille mais on a aussi
besoin d'être des voisins des amis de
manger ensemble de faire des festivals
ensemble donc un allié pas
nécessairement à tous les jours mais par
exemple un citoyen concitoyens oui alors
des fois ça peut être plus facile de
venir supporter la culture des premières
nations et de vouloir dire vous êtes
validé on va acheter vos albums de
musique on va les voir vos pièces de
théâtre
on veut entendre parler de vous au
quotidien pour pouvoir créer le lien que
de dire on va se battre ensemble
continuellement mais on a besoin de vous
aussi qu'en ces temps de se battre alors
tu comprends c'est des choses qui sont
très basés dans les émotions et dans du
véhicule parce qu'il ya une douleur à
réparer ces ports on va pas juste réparé
un pont on va pas juste à les réparer
une maison on répare un historique et
d'identité les émotions
le traumatisme vécu par des gens donc
c'est aussi d'avoir une patience face
aux gens qui ont vécu ces traumatismes
et qui sont pas prêts à voir des amis
qui sont pas prêts à vouloir avoir
quelqu'un dans leur vie qui vient les
aider ils sont en train de le faire
eux-mêmes donc la patience et la
compréhension des fois même dans
l'inaction c'est à dire dans la tente
ça peut être quelque chose qui fait de
toi un excellent tally alors merci
beaucoup des zones pourtant ta question
parce que c'est une question qui est
très difficile c'est une question qui
est très délicate aussi en espérant
avoir pu lui répondre du mieux que je
pouvais n'hésitez pas non plus à
demander autour de vous qu'est ce qu'il
faut
de vous des bons alliés et vous allez
voir que les réponses sont multiples
n'hésitez pas non plus à partager cette
vidéo à nous envoyer des questions
c'est une belle semaine